the social media company's oversight
board has decided not to allow former
president trump
back on the platform the ruling from an
independent oversight board
created by facebook says the social
media company was right when facebook's
oversight board recently upheld the
platform's ban on donald trump the
decision drew mostly negative reviews
it's a joke
the oversight board had one job give us
a clear opinion about whether facebook
was right to suspend
trump from the platform they come back
with maybe facebook has
really never suffered any consequences
themselves for allowing
dangerous lies and disinformation to
linger on its platform what facebook
twitter and google have done is a total
disgrace and an embarrassment to our
country
but the critics are wrong in at least
two major ways
first the board made the right call in
this case
it agreed that facebook was justified in
shutting down trump
after he twice posted praise of violent
rioters
even as they raised hell in the capital
it also correctly found that facebook
violated its own terms of service
by suspending trump indefinitely the
board has given mark zuckerberg and
company up to six months to render a
final decision
on the former president second and more
important the board is a serious model
for non-state governance in cyberspace
the oversight board comprises 20
individuals with backgrounds in tech
law politics and free speech activism
it's funded by an irrevocable trust set
up by facebook
and has a legally binding final say over
suspension
only up and running since the start of
this year the board has already been
twice as likely to overturn
facebook's decisions as it is to uphold
them a strong show of accountability
and seriousness of purpose in one case
the board restored images of naked
breasts and a post about cancer
that had been removed by an automated
system the board chastised the platform
for making the decision without proper
human oversight in another
facebook had removed a post that
inaccurately quoted nazi propaganda
minister joseph goebbels and compared
him to donald trump
because goebbels is on a list of
prohibited people the site took down the
post
even though it was intended as critical
of both the nazi and trump
any rules which restrict freedom of
expression must be clear
precise and publicly accessible read the
decision
which also faulted facebook for failing
to inform the user
why his post was originally taken down
these people
are really focused on trying to taking
the independence parts series as if they
want to prove the critics wrong about
being dependent and kind of a pr stunt
political scientist john samples who's a
vice president at the cato institute
is a member of facebook's oversight
board he says that a private company
moderating content on its platform is
fully in keeping with libertarian
principles
on the one hand no content moderation
people judge and then
you know probably people build tools for
controlling your feed on the other hand
you had this
corporation that existed that was a
voluntary association
and it was in the business again of
maximizing value
for shareholders to do that was not
compatible with
no content moderation and as samples
argued in a 2019 policy analysis
government regulation of social media is
likely unconstitutional
because it violates the individual's
right to free speech
there's also the issue that facebook
itself to curate its platform
and to uh in pursuit of maximizing
shareholder value
sample stresses that content moderation
is inevitable because platforms want to
create a particular sort of community
but also that it's really hard to do
consistently at scale he also
underscores
that facebook can't and shouldn't be all
things to all people
and that the best outcomes will always
come from having a variety of different
platforms
doing a lot of different things in a lot
of different ways
so that people can pick and choose among
alternatives
you don't want one set of rules for the
entire world necessarily but you also
may need different platforms and
different kind of entities providing
these services i would like to see
difference rather than its sameness that
sort of experimentation which has been
central to the success and growth of
different social media platforms
won't be possible if a growing chorus of
critics gets their way
and forces uniform rules via regulation
or antitrust
republicans in florida are trying to
restrict social media platforms
from banning users while democrats in
colorado are pushing bans on hate speech
progressives like elizabeth warren and
conservatives like josh hawley
talk about treating social media
platforms as common carriers
akin to telephone companies that would
be tightly regulated by the government
such arguments for government oversight
may well carry the day
and if they do we'll all be more limited
in not just what we'll be
able to say but where we can say